[Music]
welcome everybody my name is Leonidas
condos Nasus I'm an engineering director
at Google in charge of cloud networking
multiple products following my team the
one that I'm going to talk about today
is our cloud CDN offering and I hope
you're all well caffeinated this is
probably a more technical talk than you
might have seen otherwise so lots of
technical details so get ready okay so
how is this talk gonna be organized I'm
gonna talk a little bit about our cloud
network this is not about the CDN this
is the network itself the reason I'm
going to spend a little bit time
covering is it has affected many of the
decisions were made on how we build it
how we built the CDN offering on top of
it and now I want to make you know that
part clear and then I'm going to move on
to the content delivery aspects I'm
going to spend some time talking about
the architecture of our CDN you know the
platforms that we used to build it and
you know the logistics management how we
make sure that you know machines you
know stay up you know performing well
you know getting upgraded you know
replace that cetera et cetera I'm going
to spend some time on our mapping system
that is the heart of the CDN this is the
system that decides how users get routed
to the right you know machines and how
traffic from those machines get right it
back to users as to decisions are
independent I'm going to spend a little
bit of time on the product itself like
the features that we support and you
know some of the features that were
hoping to support in the not-too-distant
future talk about you know performance
and how we measure performance
internally and also externally and
finally close with a small demo showing
you know the benefits of you know having
Cynthia and delivery for a say graphics
you know heavy site so this is a
depiction of the Google Network Google
network changes of course you know all
the time currently we have 20 regions
with compute cycles available in them so
those are places where you can go and
get you know storage computation
like the whole heavy cloud you know
machinery we have a hundred and
twenty-five pops those are locations
where we run our edge systems and where
we do caching
this is places where you can meet our
network for private interconnect for
instance of you trying to connect your
on-prem facility to us but you know we
use them heavily for our CDN offering
and you know 13 subsea cables you know
connecting all those facilities to one
another it's one of the unique features
of Google in that we run a global
private network
unlike other cloud providers which
typically run isolated instances of data
centers in many locations we run one
global network that connects them all
this has multiple advantages it gives
you private connectivity between you
know machines that are running say in
Asia to those that are running in Europe
or you know the United States and we use
it heavily as well to do you know
various tricks you know sort of around
traffic routing you know GRE MPLS to be
able to you know stir traffic that you
know may have entire network in one
location to another location we think
that that is preferable you know for
serving purposes this is another view of
our network this is actually showing the
serving locations that we have there is
90 of those 90 different cities around
the world which sit on the edge of the
network those are the ones that we use
both for Google and cloud CDN serving
they are very large deployments
typically multiple petabytes of you know
cash ability but we have a much larger
footprint that sits off net inside ISPs
so there's about 4,000 of those
deployments they tend to be a lot
smaller in terms of size today Google
traffic is roughly half and half about
half the traffic that you know Google
has for its internal properties comes
from the O net nodes about half comes
from the earth net nodes performance
differences between those two
deployments is actually highly variable
by country you know for instance in the
u.s. we find that the on net nodes do
far better than me off net some places
you know sort of like Africa or you know
Latin America you know the inverses
to some places like you know Europe the
difference intends to be you know
practically negligible you know we don't
see much of a difference the reason that
we have both ears we want to have as
very relationship with ISPs as we can
in many of those cases is peace you know
see benefit in having caches in the
network in other cases they don't you
know we play along with you know
whatever you know suits them best so we
pick the best interconnect capability
that you know fits our ISP partners
we're working to make the often that
cache is available to Google cloud I'll
see a little bit more about that later
but right now only beyond that ones are
available for the cloud offering okay
our cloud CDN so we account for Google
and cloud CDN we account for a lot of
the Internet traffic
according to sign vine Google is
responsible for about 25 percent of all
internet bits 85 percent of that comes
from YouTube but the other parts are
actually significant and cloudy is the
fastest growing part of that traffic
it's growing faster than YouTube is
growing faster than you know the other
sources of traffic for Google we're
seeing more than 50 percent
year-over-year growth demand from over
130 countries we have had to deal with
an enormous catalog sighs so this inform
the decisions from how we built you know
those edge caches the primary reason for
that is that the the most common content
that we're serving is video video tends
to be very large and user generated
video which is what we get out of you
know YouTube we is probably the largest
catalog it's multiple exabytes of you
know data so as I said before cloud
traffic is the one that is rising the
most rapidly and that's the one where we
think that you know we have two events
the most heavy invest the most heavily
to you know help our cloud customers you
know get the benefits of our CDN and the
infrastructure as I said is shared
between Google and cloud traffic so
we've built our CDN with the following
principles number one is ease of use so
the the key innovation here
that we have a single IP for serving
content worldwide as a lot of technology
that goes behind that I will spend some
time describing you know how that
technology works why would you know a
customer care
there is often times especially for
media partners we found that they want
to work with ISPs to either you know
flat rate or low rate or you know you
know have a deal that allows you know
their content to be charged as part of a
nice big contract you know like a
cellular contract typically high-speeds
know how to do that only you know
through IP addresses they want to say
okay tell me what IP address is your con
is going to come from and being able to
give them one makes you their best
friend so it's very easy for them to
configure one IP this is the content
where it's coming from I know exactly
how to deal with that the more you give
them you know the more difficult their
life becomes we made it very easy to
activate our cloud CDN if you are
already on Google cloud yes sir the
question is can this be an ipv6 or IP
before the answer is both you can choose
so we have a single click activation on
top of our global load balancer so if
you've got you know your backends you
know sitting inside of Google Cloud and
you decide that you want cash delivery
it's a trivial turn on just one click I
will actually show you the configuration
page we care a lot about security so by
default all delivery is done you know
over SSL with no additional cost we have
also other you know programs for you
know configuring certs and uploading
them and managing them your backends the
ones that you know leave inside you know
the Google Cloud are unexposed to the
Internet so you know if you bring up you
know your VMs or you know you know you
have a back-end you know storage packet
by default that one does not have to be
exposed to the Internet traffic the CDN
takes all of the connection and then you
know connects through Google's private
network to those backends and it's got a
built in syn flood defense so because
the backends are not exposed to the
Internet and
you know attack will he no stop at the
proxy layer we have sank the largest you
know attacks you know seen in the
history of the internet you know we
believe and you know size helps you know
when you carry about 25 percent of all
Internet traffic you know it's kind of
hard for you to calm down and finally
you know performance has been another
guiding force obviously we care about
that internally we think that latency is
critical to the success of web delivery
we invest heavily on state-of-the-art
protocols so our CDN you know supports
you know HTTP to that was something that
we built and now is part of industry
standards
it supports quick which is not yet an
industry standard but it's going through
the IETF and of course you know it's
supported by Chrome and Mozilla and we
have open libraries if you want to build
your own app and we have measurements
that show that you know we have
industry-leading performance in both
latency availability and throughput so
more of that coming later ok so what
does our you know Syrian look like so at
a particular metro we have a layer of
packet forwarders where traffic is
coming in to our network the the name
for those packet for words is maglev
there is a very good sitcom paper from
2016 that describes the behavior maglevs
can do multiple millions of packets per
second they don't have to do a lot what
they have to do is you know figure out
where the right destination for a
particular packet is and you know send
it you know there typically it's right
next to them but not always I'll get
more to that later then we have our l1
proxy that is essentially the caching
proxy that you know sits at the edge of
the network there is three layers of
cash sitting right next to that l1 proxy
there is an in-memory cache for the
hardest possible you know part of the
content that tends to you know be on the
order of you know single digits of
terabytes only used for something that
is extremely hot that needs to be served
you know very very high rate there is
what we call medium cache that is on the
order of triple digits of you know
terabytes depends on the location demand
isn't always the same for all okay
on the Internet it's based on flash we
use it very heavily for you know small
contents that are very latency sensitive
but also you know some big content that
you know ends up being hot enough to
merit promotion to this cash and then
there is finally what we call a large
cache which is based on spinning this
that is typically known the double-digit
orders of petabytes it was built with
you know YouTube in mind we need a cache
that you know gives us you know 98 99
percent you know hit rate on you know
YouTube so it had to be you know fairly
large to accommodate that this you know
hierarchy of caches is what's being a
made available to our customers the l1
proxies you know will obviously you know
look things up in their you know local
cache hierarchy to see if you know it's
available if not then they will actually
go back to you know the instances you
know that have the original content
depending on the kind of instance there
may be another layer of caching is what
we call a shield cache not all origins
you know require that for instance if
your origin happens to be Google Cloud
Storage Google Cloud Storage is a fairly
big system in itself it does not need
protection so there the l1 proxies will
go to it directly but if you're running
your you know single VM for instance
there will be a layer of caches that you
know would aggregate you know requests
coming from the first layer so that you
know you don't get hammered how do we
build this these are actually pictures
of racks out in the field so the way we
build it is we have a very modular you
know horizontal architecture so what we
do if we want to augment a particular
location we just add another rack which
both increases you know storage since
you know racks are integrated storage
and egress bit pumps any increases in
our egress capability we tend to upgrade
our machines when they hit utilization
of about 70 percent and you know we have
a fairly sophisticated logistics program
to make sure that just-in-time
augmentation happen you know correctly
and the limiting factor here is the
breadth of you know network here so
those machines plug that you know
routers or switches at the edge of the
network so the breadth of
you know of that gear is one of the
limiting factors and it is one of the
things that you know forced us you know
to do work so up until a few years ago
we were using in a regular routers you
know as sold by you know people like you
know cisco juniper possibly others but
what we were observing was that the port
density on those was increasing slower
than the traffic was increasing and we
were limited both by cost and
scalability who continued to use that
technology so we kind of looked at them
and said you know what does a router do
well you know it does the GP it
exchanges information routing
information with the rest of the
internet it does packet forwarding when
it gets a packet it knows how to send it
to the you know right final destination
it does ackles so packets that are not
supposed to go out to the internet or
are not supposed to come into our
network from the internet get dropped at
that point and it does this in they're
not very effective you know packaging
from a cost perspective so we wanted to
take all those things and you know put
them together into something that you
know would be both more scalable and
cheaper so the solution to that is a
system that we call espresso full paper
and espresso has been published in this
years you know Sikkim for anybody that
was interested espresso comes you know
with three parts the first is appearing
fabric the appearing fabric is
effectively a switch it's it has no
routing smarts in it it just knows how
to connect you know sort of our side of
the network to the rest of the Internet
it's much cheaper because you know it
doesn't have all these extra
capabilities you know the routers do and
it is much more dense you can get about
10x the number of ports on a switch then
you can get on a router so now that you
have this switch you need some way to
you know ship traffic you know through
it so what we have is we have moved all
of the stuff in software so we run our
own BGP listen they're on the servers
that are sitting on the edge to get you
know the route so you know from the
other side and we pass that information
to our mapping system and I will explain
how that you know works we run two
layers of controllers a global
controller that determines where traffic
is supposed to go and that global
controller produces assignments about
once a minute
which it ships to the servers and it
tells them for this particular you know
destination I need you to send it out to
that sewage on that port and you know we
have mechanisms implemented you know
using GRE MPLS that allow us to do that
you know with the switches that we have
and we have a local controller that
essentially reacts from the order of
seconds routes on the internet come and
go somebody may withdraw out I say you
know I can't you know be reached at this
point from this particular location the
local controller is the one that's
supposed to you know take that
information and say okay you know where
else can I send it until the global
controller can compute a more optimized
assignment you know for that destination
and all of the packet processing that
you know the routers you know we're
doing has moved you know to the CPUs
earlier I showed you a picture of
something that we called maglev that was
doing packet processing on the incoming
side maglev has been extended and now
can it has a different internal name it
can do packet processing on both the
incoming and the outgoing side so we can
send the packets you know to the right
destination so logistics the difficulty
here comes from the fact that you know
we're running a very large fleet in you
know many places we have about five
percent of our machines you know in some
kind of you know repair need at any
point in time
and you know this requires you know
active management for a fleet that has
tens of thousands of servers if you were
to do that manually that would be a very
high you know burden to you know our
operation side so we've taken extensive
you know effort to automate all of this
you know work including you know
upgrades installations and repairs all
of that work happens you know through a
portal where we meet with our ISP
partners and you know we through that
portal you know have workflows that
allows us to do you know dozens of
turnips every week
dozens of repairs every week and in more
than 90% of those know Google that
actually has to touch anything it's all
automated so a machine gets shipped you
know it gets connected you know either
by a contract worker by the ice be
themselves and then from that point on
the system it automatically you know
takes over it you know logins of the
machine stalls the right software you
know brings up the BGP session you know
science it you know brings it you know
into the mapping system and you know
traffic you know starts flowing and it
knows how to do that actually in a smart
way so that you know traffic gets you
know brought up gradually so that we
don't overwhelm you know sort of the
backbone networking you know filling a
very large cash you know with a very
large you know workload so peering this
is one of the key benefits of you know
working you know with Google we have
invested very heavily with our isp
partners to make sure that we have the
best possible rich ability a lot of the
time people think of a CDN and I think
it is on the issue of machine capacity
yes machine capacity matters but you
know what we find is that machine
capacity is something that typically you
know is controlled by us you know we get
you know ship the machines we get to
install them it's it's an easier problem
to solve than something that requires an
you know an interlocutor on the other
side you know bringing up additional
peering with a partner means that both
you and them you know have to be in
agreement then you know you have to
coordinate so for peering we actively
manage and forecast are appearing you
know demand so we actually look at you
know what we think we're going to need
you know with the partners you know not
just you know over the next three months
but over the next three years and we
communicate all of that information to
them you know through the portal and we
tell them that you know this is the
locations where we see the traffic is
coming to you we think you know we need
augment we think we're going to meet the
augment you know this many months you
know from now we aim to have a one hop
distance to 98% of all ISPs on the
internet and those tend to be you know
the most major ones and we aim to have
multiple paths
into each one of those eyespace so we
are not content in having just one place
where we can connect with them we want
to connect to them in as many places as
possible for the big ones that's
actually fairly easy they understand the
value of doing that the they see you
know for their own you know benefit
because if you can't connect in multiple
places then you can give them content
close to their users so they don't have
to use their own backbone you know to
move that content around for the smaller
ones sometimes you know we have to find
alternate paths you know through transit
providers since they might not be able
to meet us in more than one location and
we use our mapping system to you know
actively manage you know those
connections and stir the traffic to the
right connection at any point in time
all right
the mapping system
okay so what is the mapping problem here
so the mapping problem is that we have
multiple paths to every user just
because of the way we're building the
system we have billions of users that
you know we need to accommodate
thankfully those billions of users can
usually be subdivided to groups so you
don't have to deal with each one of them
individually although we we try to I'll
say more about that later so but still
millions of user groups and demand
capacity and congestion you know changes
in real time so you need a system that
can deal with all those constraints so
what do we have to do we essentially
have to generate an assignment of users
to sites and links remember here it's
not enough to just send something to a
particular location you also have to
know exactly which links since you know
we're peering with multiple ISPs in that
one location are going to get used for
this particular user you have to respect
the available capacity of the machines
and the network so the supply is often
greater than it has to be greater than
the demand which is not always true you
have to respect the peer preferences our
peers are as these partners you know
give us policy that they want us to
enforce they say that you know I want
you know this particular you know set of
users to be served from here this other
particular set of users through you know
be served from you know some other place
we want to minimize cost and we want to
maximize quality you know pursuant to
those constraints so what does the
mapping system you know look like
there's a number of inputs obviously we
get you know BGP and all the other
routing data this essentially tells us
where the users are you know how far
away they are from you know any one
point in network distance Network
distance is number of hops not
necessarily you know what the latency is
between you know sort of that location
where the user is or you know what the
throughput is between that location and
the user we augment that you know with
our own observations of latency as we
serve users you know we collect
information we constantly you know run a
small trickle of users to other
locations what we call spraying so that
we can see how you know the
ideal location according to BGP compares
you know with other ones the network
topology we have built our own model for
both you know sort of our network and
you know what the internet looks like we
actually have a fairly sophisticated
model for all major ISPs we share with
them and we tell them more we see
bottlenecks not only you know sort of I
mean not on our side that you know we
keep internally we fix but we also tell
them when we see bottlenecks on you know
their side and we would work with them
you know to fix it one of the things
that was published like a few years back
was the user score this is like a
YouTube you know number that tells users
and I space you know what their score is
in terms of you know sort for video
consumption we actually spent a good you
know a couple of quarters working with
the ISPs before we made it available to
end-users to make sure that they had
every opportunity to fix their networks
and improve you know the quality and the
score that they would get on this before
we made it available to the world and
obviously load reports you know we want
to know how much traffic is going in in
one place so then the system starts you
know with a link and machine limit limit
you know computation it determines you
know what are the capacities and any
money you know sort of every one of
those elements it you know does a
preliminary candidate selection so it
says okay you know sort of for this
particular user it looks like you know
not the whole world as a good choice you
know for where to assign them to but
here's you know the top three or four or
five you know choices and then that is
fed you know to an optimizer the first
units or parts of the system are you
know eager algorithms which agree greedy
algorithms which you know simply knows
to do you know best guesses for you know
what those are the optimizer is a far
more complicated you know piece of code
it as linear programming to try and find
you know sort of the optimal solutions
and we're trying to minimize you know
sort of the size of the input data so
that it can run you know within them one
minute interval we hope to produce those
assignments about once a minute so that
you know we can shift you know traffic
around engine response to you know
changing demand from the internet for
safety reasons we archive every single
one of the outputs of all of those you
know subs
systems if you know any point in time
something goes wrong we want to be able
to restore the system to a sane state
and say okay you know we not quite sure
what is going on but here's an
assignment that you know worked fine you
know 15 minutes ago you know please use
that and you know move forward and
finally you know we actually push that
to a system that does resolution of the
user requests and you know gives them
you know the location that they should
be going that they should be going to so
this is one area where we have deviated
from you know what many other Syrians do
instead of you know relying on an
indirection which is you know quite
common of you know users to resolvers
and then you know sort of figuring out
from the resolver where the user should
be assigned we rely on either direct
integration with a player for the
YouTube or on our anycast solution to
know exactly who the client is and send
them to the right location so in the
previous picture where I was showing the
maglevs what that you know would look
like is a request that arrives you know
from a user knows exactly the client IP
for that user we don't you know need to
know the resolver the resolve is
irrelevant
everything goes always to the same IP
anyway so when the packet the request
packet comes into our network it comes
with a client IP and you know the
forwarders look at it and determine is
the local machine the optimal machine
you know to serve this piece of content
if the answer is yes then you know it's
simply a hand off you know sort of on
the local machine but some fraction of
the time that is not the case you know
the mapping system has determined but
another cache is better suited for
serving this content it will then take
that packet and forward it to you know
that other cache and responses then come
out direct so the the response is
asymmetric you know to the requests so
the response will go out from a port
that is closest you know to this user as
far as the mapping system you know was
able to determine
so I already spoke you know the first
few bullets on you know this slide
there's some additional enhancements
that we put into the mapping system to
you know make it perform as well as
possible one is the dynamic estimation
of path limits what we call end to end
limits what that feature does is it
tries to determine for any group of
users what is the capacity of the
internet between you know sort of a
cache and you know whether and utilize
the way does that actually is we we have
observed that you know the Internet has
a one level of performance you know when
it is lightly loaded which is very easy
to determine you know because it happens
at trough times in the middle of the
night there's not too many people you
know trying to use those connections so
it's never zero there's always someone
and you know I think the ratio between
trough and peak is you know sort of two
to one or so so there's still a lot of
demand you know at all times of the day
and night but because it's so much lower
you know you can sort of assume that the
network is unburdened and the
performance that you're observing at
that point in time is indicative of a
system that you know it's operating at
its best
you know capability so then you know
what we do is we constantly you know
sort of observe you know the throughput
and the latency that you know we're
seeing at peak times and if we're
starting to see that it is deviating
from that you know optimal observation
that you know we've seen you know at
rough times then we kick in you know
sort of the algorithm that you know
spreads that load you know other paths
and we measure those other paths as well
so that you know we get you know an
equalized level of performance across
all the paths
there's no point yes sir
yes so 19 one part of the world these
Dane another play a part of the world so
how do you suppress knows the reality is
that assignments are localized so an
Indian user will be sent to an Indian
you know location and they you know us
user will be sent to a u.s. location so
a night and day they are very different
and the measurement is actually relative
to the users that are supposed to that
local location are supposed to somebody
who's coming from the other side of the
world so and another big you know thing
that you know we do is we try to tell
the users apart not every user has the
same capability you know the
announcements that we get from the
internet are coming in these large
blocks that we call Sider blocks so
oftentimes in the sort of an isp will
say hey you know here's you know half a
million or you know a couple of million
users you know please route them you
know sort of this way for me and the
reality is those are not always the same
set of users they don't have the same
capabilities so we constantly observe
you know for each user what the
capability is what the capability is and
we try to divide them in smaller groups
so that you know we can assign them
independently rather than you know
treating the most one big lamp based on
how the I think you know us advertises
them to us so what we've seen as we know
we've been working on the mapping system
in improving it we have reduced the
amount of you know backbone usage like
the traffic that you know has to go from
a particular cache - you know another
exit point from about 10 percent
originally down to zero now we managed
to reduce our miss rate by properly
assigning requests to the right rack
from about 4 percent to 2 percent and we
had one other feature in our system
which is if the mapping system kind of
screws up the caches are allowed to
defend themselves by redirecting you
know some traffic away so this is only
used for YouTube which has a very very
large demand we don't use the redirect
feature for cloud CDN and our cloud
customers obviously because we don't
control you know the client and redirect
may end up being you know harmful for
them but because you will be such a
large part of the CDN you know sort of
being able to redirect that traffic away
leaves room for everybody else so and
you know modeling you know sort of the
machines and the disk capacities were
able to read you
you know the redirect rate rate from 3%
to 1% and this mapping system actually
matters on the ingress side we find that
you know if you just rely on BGP you
know which is the closest hop about 14
15 percent of the traffic would land in
a place that would not give you optimal
performance so being able to take these
incoming requests and forward them to
the right cache actually makes it
different not for you know the most of
the traffic but a good enough chunk of
the traffic to matter so here's actually
some small performance results of you
know turning on the D aggregation and
you know end-to-end limits you know it's
experiments you know showing great
buffer rate and retransmit rates you can
see market you know increases in
decreases in retransmit rate and
reductions in your rebuffing rate you
know when we turn those things on so now
that I've actually you know covered a
little bit on the technical I want to go
a bit more on the product philosophy you
know what is it that we're trying to
achieve you know with our cloud CDN so
first of all I want to say that you know
we are partners we're a cloud company
first and foremost notice Indian
companies so yes we build our own CDN
because we want to offer our customers a
one-stop shop if they want to buy
something from us and have it all you
know work seamlessly and easy then they
should be able to do that at the same
time we really understand that many of
our customers that are coming to our
cloud already have existing
relationships or they want features that
you know we are not offering yet so we
have a large number of partners and we
expect that we will continue for the
indefinite future to have a large number
or CDN partners and our customers are
free to choose you know sort of ask them
a combination many of them want to be
multi vendor that should continue to be
the case for the indefinite future
however we want to make ours as easy to
use and we hope that you know customers
you know will see the value of you know
sticking with a one-stop shop and you
know pick us obviously you know sort of
this decision rests you know with the
customers but we're making it as you
know easy to use as possible
here is actually the configuration after
you have a back-end you can see that the
enable CDN button on is just a single
check box so once you've configured a
back-end inside Google if you want to
enable caching you know the
configurations about as trivial as it
gets any other integration will surely
you know be more complicated than that I
guarantee it
we offer easy management you know log
delivery inside the cloud and you know
performance statistics all in the same
you know Pantheon view where you will
actually go and configure your CDN and
your other backends so again you know if
you're used to you know having and a
partnership we know with Google you're
actually using our other products you're
familiar with our tools the same set of
familiar tools you know will be used to
you know visualize and control you know
your CDN and the things that it
generates we've been adding features to
it so we're sort of late starters in
this game we initially focused very
heavily on infrastructure because we
were building something for internal use
and now that you know we're
externalizing you know the Saudi CDN we
are finding that our customers want more
things than you know what Google needed
internally so we've added support for
custom cache keys so if you decide that
you know you don't want your whole URL
to be a key and you can select pieces of
it we've added support for sign URLs
this is something that many of our
customers have asked you know for more
secure delivery we are partnering with
another cloud product that we have
called an VAR o to support live
streaming if it is if this is something
that you want to do or you can just do
live streaming you know in your own way
but if you want a package solution you
know then we have a full integration
with an battle obviously we seek support
that wasn't specific to the CDN but you
know once we did it you know for all
cloud you know CDN coffee for free
user-defined header insertion many of
our customers have asked for that so we
support you know certain sets of headers
that you know can be inserted into the
requests you can support multiple certs
and you know manage Dino certs as part
of our city and offering TLS cipher
selection very important for compliance
you know some customers you know
when I use particular SSL ciphers we
give them the option of selecting which
ones they want contemn take down that
you know obviously a feature that every
cd-i needs to have customers sometimes
make mistake they put up content that
they don't want to put up if it's out in
the caches you need to you know be able
to get rid of it and finally one of the
you know more recent things which is
going GA you know sort of next week it
has been announced you know for a while
now it's in open beta is what we call
our object media support you know our
origins are in video and it was one of
the things that you know classically and
customers were complaining was even
though we had great infrastructure for
video our initial implementation for
Cloud City and had a limitation on
object size that has been taken away
there's been a few things that you know
had to happen
because video content tends to be fairly
large we don't want to fetch it all in
one fell swoop into the cache so we
chunk it into you know smaller pieces
and you know we fetch the piece that is
necessary based on you know what is
being requested you know from the user
side there is one contract that we need
to have between us and the customer the
customer has to guarantee to us that
they have an origin that supports you
know range requests and you know will
actually tell us what the size of the
object is when we first you know do a
range request as we've been deploying it
I think we found like about point zero
one percent of our customers doesn't
actually have complying origins it is
surprising that they don't but we've
disabled you know the future for those
customers were working with them to fix
it and this is the thing that you know
has delayed a slightly you know
declaring J we want to make sure that
you know nobody gets harmed in the
process of rolling this out so a next
talk wouldnt be interesting is without
announcing some things that should come
you know down the pike so the number one
thing that you know we've seen is our
customers are saying that it's great
that you have a CDN it's great that it
works so well with Google Cloud but you
know what we have assets that live
outside of Google Cloud and most of them
you know talking about their own premise
and they're saying you know we need
support for that and some of them are
saying okay and we also want multi-cloud
we want to be able to run you know some
stuff on you and some stuff on your
competitors and maybe we'd like to use
your CD and you know regardless of you
know where our origins are sitting so we
are working in you know bringing that to
cloud CDN I'm hoping that by sometime
you know end of this year we'll have
something to announce the other big
thing that I announced you know sort of
earlier is we're working in extending
our class in the end to be off net fleet
that we have their difficulty there is
primarily you know how do you do any
cast of net you know you don't control
the network like you do when you're
inside you know the Google environment
we think we have a solution we're
working with our ISD partners to allow
us to you know do this any cast solution
they are very incentivized to work with
us they want to have you know the
traffic that you know Cloud City and you
know generates come from the off net
caches they would rather not have it
come through peering for those that have
not enough caches so we think we we have
the good working relationship that you
know what allow this to happen
integration with cloud armor this is a
completely separate product but it is
part of the security suite you know
people who want to be able to set both
you know sort of blocking rules for
particular IP s or countries or you know
protection for sequel injection or cross
scripting or other things so we have
support for that it is now supported you
know sort of at PLB layer we're working
on extending it you know surf to the
caching layer the the product has
already been announced it is in I think
alpha or beta forgive me for not
remembering exactly one other
optimization that we're trying to add
for customers especially know those that
want to do live events with you know
very very low latency is the assumed
public content for optimizing miss rate
right now what the CDN does is when it
gets a request it doesn't know whether
they're you know response is going to be
cacheable or not it cannot know until
you know sort of the origin has
responded because the information is
available in the headers so because it
has to be conservative and it doesn't
want to introduce latency when he gets
you know sort of say three requests for
the same thing it has to forward them
all to the origin at the same time in
order to make sure that you know they
don't get delayed and you know this mode
a customer would guarantee that the
content is always cacheable so then you
know you can forward just the first
request and leave all of the other ones
you know sort of waiting for the first
answer to come and then you can you know
get that answer back to you know all the
users that have been waiting and you
know finally you know we're working with
enviro to you know build an end-to-end
low latency live video support system we
have you know internal demonstrations
which shows that you know we can go from
encoder to you know final serving in low
single-digit we know seconds or hoping
to make that available to our clock
customers as well performance we have a
very extensive set of evaluations for
how well we're doing the probably most
important one is the one that we share
with isp partners because that helped us
not only you know sort of improve our
site but it helps you know them improve
their site as well so this is an example
of a nicely partner AS 970 18 and for
those of you who are in business should
know who that partner is and what we do
is we capture a small fraction of all
packets as we know we send them down and
we analyze you know sort of those
packets both on the outgoing you know
side and on the incoming side to detect
no bottlenecks so we also insert you
know some packets you know duplicate
packets you know which we'd use tt else
so we can see you know sort of where
they reach you know the network on the
other side and how long it takes for the
ICMP expire to come back and know that
goes into sort of an analysis system
that determines you know what the
bottlenecks in the communication are so
this is an example you know the system
Auto adjusts and essentially takes the
worst possible path and assigns that to
be you know the you know reddest part of
the spectrum in this particular case the
reddest part of the spectrum is still
you know 8 megabits per second as you
can see from you know the
slider above so this is a very well
provisioned ispeed not one that has
bought next every user is getting a
still at least you know eight megabits
per second which is more than good
enough for you know even ultra HD but we
have that for every HP partner we have
thousands of them and we share that
information with them constantly and you
know will help you know build you know
better connectivity for us and also you
know for them yes sir no this is not a
publicly available data set it is
available to Eisley partners if any of
you are an ISP or a telco then you can
sign up to the portal and get your own
information unfortunately you know for
various reasons we cannot tell one ice p
information about what other HP's are
doing internal evaluations are great the
reality is that you know we trust them
more than we trust anything externally
but I you know we fully understand that
the people that you know when I users in
the end don't necessarily have to take
our word don't you know how well we're
performing so we've commissioned a study
from an external partners the Dexys in
this case the Texas has you know this
fairly interesting system where they
have clients around the world living
inside people's you know browsers or
apps and what they do is you know
they've convinced a whole bunch of you
know websites to allow them to install a
bit of JavaScript you know sort of on
their website and after you know the
website has finished loading that
JavaScript which belongs to the exes can
kick off measurements against you know
sort of any of a number of destinations
and see you know how well you know those
destinations are performing so it's it's
a very interesting measurement system
it's got millions of vantage points or
tens of millions of an appointee around
the world and it's very difficult to
optimize for because the requests are
coming from everywhere so it's
essentially a depiction of the Internet
so the axis is actually publishing those
reports there is a much fuller list of
all the Sirians this is a cloud
conference so I'm actually presenting
the results for our biggest you know
cloud competitor AWS and cloud front
but all the results for all Syrians
including our own you know can be found
in that URL I encourage you to go and
click on the link and you know look at
them for yourself we have results for
latency we have results you know for
throughput the the early part of the
graph that was actually a problem like a
small downside down time in the east of
the exercise so for a couple of days the
data was missing but then you know sort
of the graph comes back up and
availability so one interesting thing to
note here is you can tell that this is a
real internet based measurement
availability is actually pretty bad it's
about 99 percent you know you know if
you look at you know sort of the
guarantees that you know you get from
almost every CDM it's like you know
multiple names including ourselves you
know we promise four nines but we
promise four nines on the availability
of the caches the Internet is a very
nasty place and this includes you know
people that are sitting behind you know
broken Wi-Fi sat their homes or they
turn the microwave on you know when you
know the measurement happens to you know
be going on so the failures that you're
seeing here is a sort of their real
effect so what happens you know sort of
out there in the world you still need
the four nines in the cache to get that
if you didn't have those four nines in
the cache level you'd be getting
something worse than that and that's
where you know you see some separation
you know between the CD ends the biggest
contributor you know what you're seeing
is you know what happens outside on the
internet but the city ends themselves
actually contribute to a certain extent
as well I have a small demo on the
benefits of CDN so you know we've
configured you know a back-end for the
purposes of you know this demo we put
this back-end in India so it's really
far away from here and you know we have
the origin in just for this demo we made
the origin you know publicly accessible
so we can go to it directly it is not
you know blanketed from the internet and
here I've run some trace routes I
actually run them right before you know
I came in you can see that you know the
origin is about 307 milliseconds away
from here and
CDN IP that is caching the content is
about 4 milliseconds away from here
which is pretty good so so here side by
side on the left side you have the CDN
site it is you know loading and you can
see you know how fast it is on the right
side you know you have you know
something coming you know from the
origin you can see how much lower it is
chrome has this very beautiful feature
called you know developer tools
and if you click on the network tab you
can actually see how long it takes you
know for this lighter so this page to
show so on the city inside it takes
about 300 milliseconds to load a page
that has about 15 fairly large you know
images this is a CDN configuration that
includes you know quick so it's our best
protocol you know for loading persistent
connections the you know right hand side
is sort of an origin that is going over
HTTP 1 1 so it's not really a fair
comparison but it's one that I you know
create it you know showcase you know the
difference I encourage you you know the
slides will be available when you go
back to your homes click on the city and
you know site then you know run some
trace routes it'll be the same IP you'll
be able to see that it's always a few
milliseconds away from you with that I'd
like to you know sort of summarize and
say that you know we focused on
ease-of-use security and performance I'm
not going to repeat you know the the
bullets those are you know sort of the
key aspects of the CDN that you know we
want to share with our customers and I
have an obligation to also tell you that
there's a lot of you know beautiful
networking talks that next I encourage
you to attend as many of them as you can
and learn about you know the great
network that you know Google cloud has
to offer
and since everybody likes you know shrug
if you want a beautiful poster you know
nice glossy to put on your wall of you
know how great you know the Google you
know network is G dot Co slash poster
put your information and we'll happy to
give you one thank you
[Music]